اعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه للجزيره عن
قلقها ازاء ادراجي محكمه مصريه صحفيين على
لائحه الارهاب بينهم صحفيون في شبكه
الجزيره وقال متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه للجزيره ان واشنطن قلقه بشان
استخدام محاكم مصريه لتوجيه تهمم تتعلق
بممارسه حريه التعبير داعيا الحكومه
المصريه للافراج الفوري عن المعتقلين بتهم
تتعلق بالحريات وكانت السلطات المصريه قد
اددرت اسماء عشرات الصحفيين بينهم اربعه
صحفين من شبكه الجزيره هم عبد الرحمن حسين
وانا الزكي وعمل القزاز وسامحي مصطفى على
لائحه الارهاب وفق قرار من محكمه المصريه
انضموا الينا من واشنطن مراسل للجزيره
احمد هزيم احمد فسر لنا اكثر
محمد هذه هذه الرد من الخارجيه الامريكيه
على طلبات الجزيره والموقف الذي جاء في
هذا الرد من اعتباري ان استخدام محاكم امن
الدوله لادراج صحفيين او لادراج اشخاص
عبروا عن ارائهم على لائحه لائحه الارهاب
المصريه هو عمل يقلق الولايات المتحده
ودعت السلطات المصريه الى الكف عن القيام
بهذه الممارسات والافراج عن من تم
اعتقالهم في السابق بسبب ارائهم او بسبب
التعبير عن ارائهم وهذا ايضا يظهر ان
الاداره الامريكيه او الخارجيه الامريكيه
بالتحديد لن تتبنى ولا ولا تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار الروايه المصريه التي استخدمت
لادراج هؤلاء على لائحه الارهاب وملف عالق
او ملف شائك في العلاقه
هي علاقه تحالف بين واشنطن وبين القاهره
ترتبت عليها كثير من الامور التي قوضت هذه
العلاقه مثل تجميد كثير من المساعدات
الامريكيه التي تقدم الى مصر على مدى
السنوات القليله الماضيه هذا الموقف سيشكل
ضاغطا على القاهره لكنه ايضا موقف
ليس له هذا الدلال القوي التي يمكن ان
تعكر او تؤدي الى
الى ضرر كبير في العلاقه بين واشنطن
والقاهره
المسؤولين الامريكيين ومن تحدثنا اليهم في
وزاره الخارجيه لا يزالون يرون بان
القاهره هي الشريك استراتيجي مهم للولايات
المتحده وان ملف حقوق الانسان هو ملف
خلافي بين واشنطن وبين وبين السلطات
المصريه هناك تتضغط الولايات المتحده بين
الفينه والاخرى على القاهره في هذا الملف
لكن تبقي تعاونها في الملفات الاخرى حاضرا
رغم هذه هذه هذا الملف الذي يقوض العلاقه
بين الطرفين محمد شكرا لك احمد هزيم من
واشنطن